wie gut dass es schneekanonen gibt dann
könnte die olympischen winterspiele auch
im schnee armen peking stattfinden
andere chinesische kanonen sind aber
weit bedeutsamer womit wir bei der
politischen dimension der spiele werden
soll man in einem solchen land überhaupt
solche events abhalten wenn doch sport
und nicht politik im vordergrund stehen
soll
olympia in peking wie umgehen mit china
jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet aus shanghai ist
jürgen kurz sie waren früher
parteipolitisch aktiv bei den
bündnisgrünen leben jetzt seit fast 20
jahren in china und leitet dort die
niederlassung eines deutschen
unternehmens eines ihrer leitmotive auch
für ihre arbeit ist ein freundliches und
tolerantes miteinander zwischen china
und deutschland ebenfalls zugeschaltet
tobias preuss sie sind vizepräsident von
athleten deutschland das ist ein
unabhängiger verband der kader athleten
kader-athleten heißt also die im
nationalkader organisiert sind sie
setzen sich dafür ein echtes
mitspracherecht der sportler ein das
spielt heute eine wichtige rolle in
dieser diskussion und sie sind auch für
grundsätzliche veränderungen im
deutschen und internationalen sports
system im studio sind die die kirsten
tableau sie sind asien expertin bei der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik und shi ming ist bei uns freier
journalist sie stammen aus china und
leben seit über 30 jahren in deutschland
herr preuß welchen blick haben sie denn
auf die winterspiele muss noch sagen sie
sind wassersportler
aber interessieren sich sicherlich auch
für andere sportarten welchen blick
haben sie denn auf diese winterspiele in
peking ein lachendes und ein weinendes
auge
absolut also natürlich bin ich
wassersportler bin aber auch begeistert
das neue board fahrer dementsprechend
die hinter spiel ist nämlich allzu fern
und der ganz wichtig also beinen und
lachenden auge absolute weinend wenn man
auch die situation dort wie sie vor ort
schaut wie sie ist ist das ein weines
ein lachendes aber weil wir uns
natürlich auch auf die wettkämpfe um die
olympischen spiele freuen
flo wie sehr belastenden die themen
menschenrechte und co wie das ist ja
keine sportthemen aber wie sehr belasten
diese themen die spiele in peking die
belasten die spiele sehr wohl und vor
allem auch im ausland denn innerhalb
chinas sind viele normale leute
natürlich sehr dafür die stehen auch
unter sehr strikten propaganda
vorkehrungen hershey die kp in china die
braucht einen erfolg bei diesen spielen
was ist denn der erfolg oder was wäre
der erfolg für china für die
chinesischen führung wenn man sich diese
olympische spiele den ablauf und die
resultate anzieht es gibt drei
unterschiedlichen erfolgskriterien das
eine ist er wegen der pandemie das hat
die regierung schon so ein bisschen
vorsichtig angedeutet dass nach diesem
winter spielen bitteschön keine
ausbreitung von der pandemie und der
chinesin geben soll das wäre ein erfolg
schon dass die europäische spiele
überhaupt dann ohne große zwischenfälle
stattfinden das wäre der zweite erfolg
der dritte ist ja putin kommt nach
peking und sie die impfung wird wird
sich mit ihm sprechen sicherlich nicht
über ukraine oder mich nicht direkt über
die ukraine aber über eine mögliche
geopolitische an der hunde beiden mächte
vielleicht das heißt es geht ja nicht
nur um schaulaufen auf der eisfläche
sondern auch politisches schaulaufen
insofern hat das auch die politische
dimension her kurz was bedeuten ich sage
ja sie leben seit 19 jahren in china was
bedeuten denn die olympischen spiele für
china diese olympischen spiele ist
dieses ereignis ein thema für die
menschen dort inwieweit ist das in der
öffentlichkeit präsent
natürlich ist das in der öffentlichkeit
präsent das fernsehen ein und schon
sehen sie dass die menschen sind
begeistert von der idee dass in china
olympische spiele sind freuen sich drauf
wundern sich aber immer vom großen fall
in europa in deutschland basiert war das
hier so gut wie keiner versteht von den
menschen aber
ansonsten sind die chinesen unterdessen
eine sehr sportbegeisterte nation adidas
nike all diese unternehmen machen hier
unter der sauce und das wird sich auch
weiterentwickelt jetzt kommt der
wintersport ins rennen und auch mit
wucht gut das hat er heute auch der ioc
präsident thomas bach noch mal geäußert
olympische spiele das motto der
olympischen spiele ist ja dass sich die
jugend der welt trifft und zwar
möglichst unbeschwert und offen das soll
bei olympischen spielen ja auch
gelegentlich passiert sein eigentlich
kann davon ja jetzt keine rede mehr sein
ist ja eher eine kasernierung von
sportlern herr preuß kann das sein dass
das die zukunft der spiele sind
es jetzt in china noch unter der
besonderen bedingungen von coffey das
ist muss nicht immer so sein aber hat
sich da was verändert in der in der
machart in der außenwirkung in der
ganzen in dem ganzen verständnis dass
spiele vermitteln
nun ja es ist ja schon schon zu
beobachten dass die dass die spiele
durchaus kommerzialisiert wurden in den
letzten jahren es ist sehr viel mehr
geld rein geflossenen die spiele von mal
zu mal weil das wissen es auch mehr und
das ist natürlich ein ausmaß angenommen
hat
sich sogar viele länder sich deswegen
auch weigern spielen noch auszurichten
das natürlich in dem sinne von der
betrachtungsweise keine keine schöne
entwicklung dass die die aufmerksamkeit
und die die mediale präsenz natürlich
der olympischen spiele im sportlichen
sinne da ist begrüßen wir natürlich aber
das sollte sich dann auch wiederum nicht
nur auf alle vier jahre beziehungsweise
zwei respektive mit dem winter
olympischen spielen sollte sich nicht
darauf nur begrenzen und wenn wir uns
jetzt diese besondere spiele anschauen
und aber auch andere großveranstaltungen
und sportlichen rahmen die jetzt noch
zukünftig
abgehalten werden ist es eben eine
entwicklung die wir auch kritisch
beäugen im sinne von der
demnach kommen der sorgfaltspflicht von
den internationalen
sportverbänden und wie sie agieren und
und welche verantwortung sie auch
mittragen und
dies das
stößt uns halt eben auch dass sie sich
dieser verantwortung häufig nicht
stellen und dementsprechend folge
problematiken mit sich ziehen die die es
zu verhindern gilt es gibt es ja eine
vergabepraxis bei der fifa und bei dem
ioc dem internationalen olympischen
komitee wo man das gefühl hat wer die
meiste kohle auf den tisch legt und kein
ärger macht der kriegt dann auch den
zuschlag welche kriterien sollten dafür
die zukunft gelten wenn man das jetzt
betrachtet an den spielen entwickeln
gute frage also das nächste ort ist auch
soweit ich weiss katar da geht es bei wm
es war genau da ist natürlich auch sie
viel geld im spiel sozusagen
eigentlich schade dass wir davon reden
dass geld im spiel ist denn fußball ist
ja ein spiel und sport ist sport ich bin
inzwischen irgendwann der punkt
angekommen wo ich denke sollten die
olympiade nicht jetzt einfach zurück
nach griechenland gehen und bleiben das
ist wirklich wieder rein sport wird und
jetzt nicht eben nicht politik und nicht
so in der art und weise massenhaft geld
das würde ich spiele einfach die
winterspiele hätten wahrscheinlich gegen
ein ähnliches anliegen peking
es wird ja jetzt aus politischen gründen
wir wissen das ja wird ja von einigen
von menschenrechts-organisationen ein
boykott der spiele insgesamt gefordert
auch manche sportler fordern den
sportlichen der boykott andere haben
wollen einen diplomatischen boykott
deutschland verhält sich da zurück aber
sie schickt keine spitzenpolitiker hin
welche reaktion ist denn aus ihrer sicht
angemessen
es kommt dort wandern auf die
perspektive der westlichen demokratien
wenn man wirklich betonen will wie die
bundes außenministerin berbalk betont
dass das dann eine werteorientierte
außenpolitik geben muss einen
menschenrechts betonen der außenpolitik
dann kann man natürlich auch in diesen
großen events nicht schweigen nicht
einfach so tun als wäre nichts gewesen
und wenn man aus der perspektive der
internationalen entwicklungsziele das
betrachtet dann ist es eine große frage
zu stellen weil es sie in china
natürlich eine wunderbare
schnee eis regionen gibt
dort gibt es sogar soziale probleme
arbeitslosigkeit
in diese regionen sind über 30 prozent
wenn man also die spieler dort
veranstalten lassen würde man nicht nur
den sport viel billiger machen die
nachhaltigkeitsziele viel besser
erreichen man würde sogar die menschen
vor außen doch wirtschaftlich helfen
können das ist aber nicht der fall dann
ist die frage dass die olympischer
spiele obwohl es sehr leicht in russland
bei sotschi wurde es in peking natürlich
ein geopolitischer bühne anbietet auch
bei sony war das nicht sehr viel anders
und da ging es um politik ob man das
zugibt oder nicht ist es ein teil des
das ist diesmal wieder einen teil und da
sollten auch die ioc etwas ehrlicher
werden wenn sie ihr sagen wir machen wir
sport wir haben mit der politik nichts
zu tun doch haben sie mit politik zu tun
thomas bach zum beispiel hatte sich
lebensweise sogar für einen chinesischen
tennis da eine frau verwenden lassen die
da wegen sexueller belästigung oder
sexuellen missbrauchs mai war das grün
vorher einen kanal also was ist das
natürlich sportlich intension dass das
heißt natürlich klar ioc kann sich nicht
mehr darum herum drücken und ich glaube
je nach perspektiven sollten wir uns
wirklich ernsthaft in frage stellen wie
wir die olympische spiele entweder
entflechten wie sie das vorgeschlagen
haben dass nur reiner sport reine
begegnung von menschen oder wir
akzeptieren die realität und benennen
die realität auch so gut jetzt kommt
wahrscheinlich eine andere position herr
kurz den kopf geschüttelt vor haben sie
auch schon angedeutet dass man in china
nicht verstehe die reaktion das
verhalten des westens warum fühlen sich
die chinesin dan ungerecht behandelt
das ist eigentlich relativ einfach zu
beschreiben schauen sie sich an was in
den letzten tagen und wochen in den
westlichen medien enden speziell auch in
den deutschen medien dann habe ich dann
den rechten zugriff auch passiert man
hat das gefühl und das ist auch bei den
chinesen kommt das auch genau so an dass
journalisten aus deutschland nach china
gehen mit einer vorgefertigten
geschichte diese geschichte hat man den
kopf und dann produziert man eine story
die geben das auch bestätigt was man
vorher im kopf hatte und dann wundern
sich die journalisten das ist ja auch
heute in einigen berichten darüber
gekommen dass die chinesen gar nicht
mehr mit ihnen interviews machen wollen
dann sagen sie alle natürlich ist die
erklärung dann das wird von der die zwei
entsprechend behindert nur also meine
beobachtung oder das was ich von den
chinesen persönlich sehe und ich bin ja
nur in china seit fast 20 jahren
gespräche mit den menschen auch hier den
menschen sagen einfach wenn wir uns mit
denen uns unterhalten die darin uns
sowieso das wort im mund herum china hat
eine hat wenn sie sich den den edelmann
die edelmann
umfragen anschauen man fortan schieber
hat im vergangenen jahr in der
zustimmung 9 prozentpunkte zugelegt bei
der bevölkerung die bevölkerung ist hoch
zufrieden mit dem was in china passiert
deutschland ist schlusslicht in der
edelmann der edelmann voll mit minus 12
prozent minus 12 punkten aber die ganze
welt geht nach china und sagt tina du
machst was falsch das ist falsch das ist
falsch das ist falsch das macht ihr
falsch und was sagen die chinesen
natürlich die menschen das ist unser
land haltet euch daraus gehabt man dazu
sagen und habe auch nicht so ne kirchen
setzte kurz die sagen die ich lese und
gar keine lust mehr mit westlichen mit
den vertretern zu reden bis hatte man
das gefühl dass westliche
medienvertreter und das sagen ja so
ziemlich alle überhaupt keine
gelegenheit gehabt mit chinesen zu
treten ja genau genau das ist das
ergebnis eines eines kreislaufs der
aufgebaut wurde die westlichen medien
vertreter tatsächlich kommen mit
vorgefertigten wahrnehmungen und
geschichten an ich kann mich ja immerhin
scheint ja also ich mich als ich kurz
bevor ich nach china gefahren bin ist
nicht von uns gewesen er hat seine
geschichte er hat seine geschichte
gehabt hat nichts gefunden was das
bestätigt und hat man lauter
spekulationen im spiegel in breiter
ethnischer bereichs verbreitet macht
motto disneyland das chinesische
disneyland ingenieuren und das geht aber
auch in anderen stellen so schauen sie
sich die berichterstattung über die
dörfer jetzt wo die entsprechenden
olympia anlagen aufgebaut wurden schauen
sich das an man hat eine meinung die es
geht nicht darum was über das land zu
erfahren man will sich gar nicht mit dem
land beschäftigen sondern man will das
was man als narrativ in deutschland
sowieso schon in der umwelt hat will man
bestätigt haben und sucht beweise genau
das zu bestätigt gut über die auf die
unruhen kommen wir gleich noch zu
sprechen
sie haben dann in peking gearbeitet
komponenten was kurz gesagt können sie
das bestätigen
dann müssten wir ja eigentlich als
journalisten nicht mehr hinfahren werden
wir schon vorgefertigt gemeinde also ich
wäre da muss ich schon zugeben sehr
andere meinung als herr kurz und ich
glaube das ist genau ich war selber
39 jahre meines lebens in china oder in
hongkong also ich kenne das auch und
bei der 2008 olympiade war ich vor ort
habe berichtet ich glaube dass man muss
einfach verstehen dass in china ein sehr
verzerrtes bild der realität herrscht
wegen ein extrem großes internes
propaganda system es funktioniert nach
außen es funktioniert nach innen das
heißt information management auf
englisch so gesagt ja informations
management und es wird ins detail
reingegangen was darf das volk wissen
was darf es nicht wissen was soll s
wissen wie soll es denken und daraus
entsteht natürlich nach so vielen jahren
von dieses minutiösen management eine
spinne gewisse realität die vielleicht
immer wieder sehr realitätsfernen ist
keine frage dass unter diesen umständen
die normale leute in china
also was die da wirklich wissen glauben
wollen hoffen es ist schwer zu wissen
nicht würde da ehrlich gesagt kein
edelmann
barometer zitieren denn man kann hat man
muss man muss ja auch zusammen mit dem
staat immer dieser meinungs- und
untersuchung in pe in china führen das
darf man nicht alleine machen sie sind
ja in china geboren aufgewachsen wie
haben sie das erlebt auch schon jetzt im
vergleich zu heute ja also meine
generation wächst mit dem spruch um im
leben gut dazustehen dass du nicht sagen
was du machst und nicht machen was du
sagst also zwei gesichter das hat nicht
nur mit der unterdrückung zu tun das hat
auch mit der vorsicht zu tun weil man
eben nicht weiß wer in meiner umgebung
mich demnächst wieder an zeigt ja
inzwischen gibt es ja eine internen
einschätzung dass allein im letzen
letzten drei jahren
hochschullehre entlassen werden weil
ihre studierenden sie angezeigt haben
weil die dann im unterricht irgendetwas
erzählt haben das berichteten und nicht
einmal die westliche medien das
berichtete sogar die chinesischen medien
es gibt natürlich auch kritik jetzt
wegen pandemie im chinesischen social
media gibt es leute die da vor den
kameras sitzen und schreien und sagen
sie haben uns eingesperrt
das sind keine westlichen journalisten
das sind chinesen in den ich in den
dschihad
das sind chinesen in jinzhou das sind
die chinesen sogar einigen
und jetzt sind wir
können diese sie nicht alle weg beamen
wir können nicht alle sagen das sind
eigentlich nur von westlichen medien
gesteuerte chinesen ich erkläre das so
dass in der tat wie sie das gesagt haben
dass menschen aus unterschiedlichen
motiven sich jeweils anders verhalten
gegenüber
landes und freundlicher lang maßen
feindlichen langnasen
man muss sie ernst nehmen aber man muss
sie in der komplexität ärmsten man kann
nicht sagen weil sie mir das gesagt
haben ist es auch so ja natürlich wenn
ich in peking wäre und so ein netter
europäischer herr zu mir kommt und sagte
wie sehen sie das ich würde auch sagen
ja wunderbar warum sollte ich mir
eigentlich hier probleme
zu spielen lassen werden wir in dieser
herr nach außen sagte dieser chinese
sagte wunderbar da passiert mir gar
nichts
aber wenn die irgendjemand mehr
wirklichen über über wie chat anspricht
ein chinese und sagte wie system bei dir
ist es locklear dann neige ich auch dazu
sagen wir die die tür draußen ist es
geschlossen wir haben das nicht
geschlossen irgendjemand hat es
geschossen das sind zwei container
aussagen die beide ihre psychologie
haben ich will nicht sagen dass der
gleiche menschen zweimal gelogen hat
aber sie passen sich an ich will kommt
gleich auf dieses möglicherweise auch
schwierige verständnisproblem zwischen
deutschland und oder den westen und
china noch mal zurück herr preuß show
must go on das hat man einen
ioc-präsident avery brunch gesagt in
münchen also 72 die show muss
weitergehen die spiele müssen
weitergehen
das war ein ganz anderer anlass es gegen
diesen terroranschlag aber wenn wir
jetzt auf peking sid manche fragen sich
warum finden diese spiele statt nicht
nur wegen der politischen hintergründe
sondern auch wegen coffee dass das
möglicherweise ein super sprecher event
wird am ende so viele menschen sich
infiziert haben das möglicherweise auch
ökonomische gefährdungen auftreten wie
ist es aus sicht eines sportlers eines
athleten wie geht man mit dieser
situation um das er sich eigentlich auf
die sportereignisse freut auch die
wettbewerber da hat er jahrelang hielt
daraufhin gearbeitet gleichzeitig aber
unter solchen prekären bedingungen dann
sport bleiben muss
ja das ist natürlich eine ganz ganz
besondere situation dieses mal
dem ford weggeschoben natürlich also
wenn wenn es profis gibt in puncto
fokussieren und die die äußeren
bedingungen ausblenden dann sind das
natürlich sport wählen und aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich diese
situation in diesem jahr eine ganz
besondere und die athletinnen mit denen
wir gesprochen haben da ist auch absolut
die die vorfreude auf die olympischen
wettkämpfe zu spüren also es ist
definitiv wird wird sich darauf die auf
die wettkämpfe gefreut das wird davon
berichtet dass es das ist tolle
wettkämpfe
es ist aber gleichzeitig werden aber
auch eben erreichen uns berichte wie
jedes jahr wie auch die vorbereitung
dahin waren die nervenzellen auch diese
letzten wochen waren in ständiger angst
sich doch mit dem chor mit 19 zu
infizieren und dann auf den auf die
erfüllung dieses traumes und das
woraufhin nicht nur wie sie sagen den
letzten jahren häufig wirklich ja ein
ganzes leben dem unterstellt war
dann vielleicht doch noch aufgrund einer
infektion
dass das ganze hätte platzen können was
ja schon passiert ist glaube ich
reaktion was er schon passiert als bei
der arbeit auch dass deutsche sportler
schon positiv getestet und sind jetzt
können sie sich in ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen eher sicherlich sehr gut rein
versetzen sie sind ja gar nicht
olympischen dorf in peking sondern hier
in deutschland aber wie kann man unter
solchen bedingungen eigentlich
leistungssport treiben unter solchen
schwierigen äußeren bedingungen
ja
ja ich kann man also wie gesagt wir sind
athleten sind profis darin sich voll zu
fokussieren und eben eben die äußeren
bedingungen auszublenden und in diesem
konkreten fall muss man natürlich auch
sagen dass die bedingungen für alle
gleich sind
nichtsdestotrotz sind auch da eben die
die befürchtungen diese diese ob ja
schon fast obskuren
vorstellungen der möglichkeiten die das
er geht mit mit manipulierten tests oder
wie man der konkurrenz aus dem weg
räumen könnte die ja trotzdem alle ihre
band masse abend vor sotschi haben uns
auch
vorstellen können dass das urin proben
durch wände durchgegeben werden und so
weiter aber ja es ist möglich definitiv
volle leistung abzurufen und das werden
die athleten auch mit allen mit allen
mitteln versuchen werden sich dann voll
auf die auf die spiele und auf die
wettkämpfe konzentrieren
und wie gesagt die die freude auf die
wettkämpfe selbst die ist auch nach wie
vor vorhanden herr kurz wenn jetzt noch
mal kurz auf die politik chinas eingehen
wie lebt es sich denn in china unter
diesen
bedingungen ich glaube sie sind noch in
einem container hotel untergebracht sind
kürzlich aus deutschland zurückgekehrt
man muss glaube ich zwei wochen in einem
solchen quarantäne hotel bleiben bevor
man wieder nach china einreisen darf wie
lebt es sich unter diesen bedingungen in
china
also zuerst mal china hat von anfang an
eine null courbit politik gefahr als die
pandemie ausbrach in china also
zumindest das wahrgenommen wurde in
china hat china erst mal wie jedes land
der welt auch im dunkeln herumgestochert
und musste nicht was passiert hat
deshalb auch sehr radikal erstmal die
gesamte provinz hubei abgegrenzt und da
habe ich auch die ausbreitung des
corona in chinas
unterbunden das ist der erste punkt erst
mal diese strategie hat sich bis heute
nicht verändert wird auch von der
bevölkerung massiv eingefordert die wird
jede bedrohung wird seitens der
bevölkerung auch kritisch hinterfragt
natürlich kann man betroffen ist weil
man nicht zu dem zeitpunkt an in eine
quarantäne oder einer abgeriegelten
bereich kommt vorübergehend ist dass ihr
unangenehm allerdings habe ich
beobachtet und das habe ich gesehen ich
habe mitarbeiter die in japan hängen
geblieben sind ein huber hängengeblieben
sind zu der damaligen zeit wird man auch
sehr gut versorgt da sind die
infrastruktur die
versorgungsinfrastruktur ist super
aufgebaut wenn man jetzt nicht so wie
ich gerade aus deutschland zurückkommt
und dadurch zwei wochen in einem
quarantäne hotel verbringen muss was der
0 politik geschuldet ist wird es sich
prima ich bin in den seit märz 2020
haben wir die firma geöffnet wieder oder
war schon ende februar haben wir die
firma wieder geöffnet und seit dieser
zeit haben wir sozusagen kaum eine
einschränkung tatsache ist natürlich das
lokale politik und lokale
gesundheitsbehörden zum teil sehr
merkwürdige reaktionen zeigen das hat
auch einschränkungen nur wenn ich dann
lese dass alles shipping entscheidet ist
das natürlich quatsch das sind sehr
lokale interpretation von regularien die
dann zum teil die leute unnötig
blockieren das ist so
der kommt vielleicht habe ich hätte noch
gerne frage zur wirtschaft auch zu ihrem
bereich gibt es eine gewisse
befürchtungen wenn die omikron variante
jetzt auch in china grassiert dass das
massive konsequenzen für die wirtschaft
hat dass viele menschen nicht mehr zur
arbeit kommen können dass der export
stock dass unsere lieferketten weiterhin
sehr in mitleidenschaft gezogen dann
sehen sie diese gefahr
also
was wir beobachten auch jetzt mit
omikron ist die tatsache wie gesagt dass
diese variante schneller durch
quarantäne blockaden durch geht das
passiert definitiv das sind meistens
mitarbeiter von flughäfen von
krankenhäusern die das dann nach draußen
auch tragen und dann kommt dass er
schnell hoch china hat aber ein sehr
schnelles testsystem und
erfassungssystem digitalisiert das wird
bei der digitalisierung dann auch sehr
schnell erfasst und das führt dann dazu
dass regionen vorübergehend mittlere
risikogebiete sind ganz selten hoch
risikogebiete diese mittel risikogebiete
entwickeln eine eigene politik das kann
eine region also innerhalb einer stadt
sein entwickeln eigene politik und dann
ist das reisen in oder aus diesen
regionen erschwert ich sehe nicht dass
dadurch die gesamte wirtschaft blockiert
wird ich sehe nur wir haben gerade wir
arbeiten sehr viel im außendienst im
servicebereich das bedeutet für uns
einfach mehr jonglieren der logistik
mehr
planungsarbeit ist nicht angenehm ist
und problem definitiv aber ist kein
punkt der uns in irgendeiner form
ernsthaft bisher hindert wir haben im
vergangenen jahr eines der besten
ergebnisse der firmengeschichte erreicht
gut das ist jetzt das was ihre
persönliche erfahrung sind
china alles paletti auch was jetzt das
thema profit angeht auch für die
menschen mit deko witt umgehen müssen
also ich denke es gibt auch hier sehr
unterschiedliche bilder ein beispiel sie
haben eine 13 millionen stadt die wurde
dann quasi
weitgehend flächendeckend in lobt
angespannte von der polygamie kriege
menschen hier ja
man kann natürlich von den maßnahmen
halten was man will aber inzwischen gibt
es auch die stadtregierung hinzu dass
die anfangs maßnahmen fast unmöglich
machen dass bestimmte bezirke mit gemüse
fleisch reis nicht versorgt werden
konnten
das also menschen wirklich zum beispiel
eine schwangere frau ein missgeburt er
erleiden musste weil das krankenhaus sie
ablehnte und solche beispiele räumte
auch die die provinzregierung scheint
sie ein sie entschuldigt sich also ist
es nicht so dass das diese maßnahmen
keine
weitreichenden konsequenzen für die
menschen um andere menschen haben im
gegenteil sie haben enorme konsequenzen
dann gibt es natürlich auch die menschen
die dann angst haben und sagen ja liebe
so als auch dass wir dann auch dran
kommen also sie sind sehr hin und
hergerissen lockten bei anderen
wunderbar lockte bei uns bitte nicht
weil es dann sofort uns einschränkt aber
das ist menschlich dass es auch hier in
europa nicht sehr viel anders die frage
ist jetzt im hinblick auf die
olympischen spiele ein doppelte
peinliche frage die chinesische
regierung betont immer wieder dass die
fälle aus dem ausland wieder eingeführt
werden ja und wir crackdown jede kleine
ausbrüche von infektionen und isolieren
dieser sportler die reisen ein und sechs
stück sind schon schon positiv getestet
und sie sind auch noch alle willkommen
ja ja das heißt ich jetzt auch nicht so
ganz verstanden dass man in china zwar
sagte von außen kommt kommt dieses für
diese variante oder überhaupt hier das
virus eingetragen aber gleichzeitig
wollen wir ja auch hier die olympischen
spiele veranstalten
das kann man ja nicht ohne ausländische
teilnehmerinnen und ein afghane und es
ist wirklich ein sehr komisches bild im
moment ich habe eine
menschenrechtlerin in kanada sagen hören
vor zwei tagen dass die das olympische
dorf jetzt quasi zu ein gehobenes
internierungslager als sehr gehoben
natürlich geworden ist weil es so also
derartig abgeriegelt und die belgische
frau natürlich
dachte sie würde jetzt ein innen ins
krankenhaus gebracht werden ist ein
anderer zum oder zum dorf gebracht und
dann doch doch isoliert in
krankenhäusern zuständen und so in einem
hotel und ist zusammengebrochen
irgendwie so als er hat wirklich
gelitten und ich glaube das ist schon
ist zeigt ja wirklich wie wichtig es der
kp china ist und zieht ihn persönlich
denn diese olympische spiele sind ein
prunkstück für sie persönlich das muss
man so verstehen es ist einfach so denn
er ist ja chef nicht warum war 2008 bei
der sommerspiele war er auch leiter von
der sonde gruppe die dieser sommer
signalisiert haben
der nidda war dies erst 2012 superman
chef geworden aber er ist so im gang
gebracht worden quasi mit der bi 2008
olympiade sprich es ist einfach ein sehr
komisches bild wenn man sich überlegt
wie detailliert und forciert man jetzt
in der bevölkerung zu geht mit dieser
mit diese kontrolle wegen
cupid ich sage nicht dass es völlig
falsch ist natürlich nicht aber und dann
sieht ja für diese ausländische gäste
für für denn für den ruf der olympiade
und für p&g und für china für die
chinesischen träumen also traum so
scheine dream von der kp machen wir doch
jetzt frei also das ist schon sehr
manipuliert jetzt haben sie diese
sportlerin von internet sehr
angesprochen ja herr kurz er
ja bitte es einfach mal sich vor augen
halten denn china die politik des
westens übernommen hätte hätten wir
heute drei millionen todesfälle in china
also das ist überhaupt nicht in diesem
land auszuhalten die red bull will
bevölkerung hätte den kaiser vom hof
gejagt das ist das alte system
es gibt zwar keinen kaiser mehr aber die
regierung hätte das nicht überstehen
können die bevölkerung ist hochgradig
glücklich und ich verstehe gar nicht
wieso man sich im westen darüber den
mund fusselig geredet dass china einen
anderen weg und zwar sehr erfolgreich
geht vielleicht ist es ein das problem
dass man es selbst so schlecht gemanagt
hat wir haben 200.000 tote in
deutschland wir haben fast eine million
tote in den usa das ist ein miserables
gesundheitsschutz ergebnis also es war
er auch schon gut gewesen wenn man am
anfang in china die wahrheit hätte
gesagt hätte über diese
die leute einfach jetzt gesagt
und jetzt
denen das wort weggenommen und das sind
auch einige gestorben und so also das
ist jetzt eine andere sache und ich habe
also ich sehe uns ist auch wichtig das
ist meine keine hier jetzt auch gesagt
hat dass die der versucht dieses virus
zu kontrollieren schlecht oder falsch
ist es hat ja keiner gesagt denke ich na
das ist eine andere frage vielleicht was
sie da ansprechen also alle chinesen
sind glücklich wenn ich jetzt sagen kurz
richtig verstanden habe
also es gibt ein anderes thema
enthalten ist ansonsten sind die
chinesen sehr zufrieden jeder schlucht
weil die menschen
im moment das was ich lieber sprechen
erstens sie sind es nicht die chinesen
ja sie können dichte 1 4 milliarden
menschen schon mal gefragt haben dass
das das ist ausgeschlossen
moment moment moment ich habe auch nicht
1,4 milliarden chinesen befragen können
aber ich sage ganz mit sicherheit dass
nicht alle chinesen glücklich sind ja
das konnte das ist dermaßen unter
auflagen dass sie eine begeisterung für
mein land haben dass das ehrt sie ja
aber bitte übertreiben sie auch nicht ja
also diese millionen menschen die
wirklich tage lang in der kälte stehen
müssen um diese pcr-test innerhalb von
einer woche zweimal durchzuziehen das
ist kein spaß dass er da können sie mal
fragen und und unter uns ist zufrieden
die menschen dies werde noch lange die
ich im moment lassen sie mich mal
ausreden ja zu geben sind die menschen
noch lange nicht die haben ihre probleme
sie haben wir reichen nicht die probleme
die hier im westen so haargenau
beschrieben sind da bin ich bei ihm aber
wenn sie jetzt sagen alle chinesen sind
begeistert das ist nun zufrieden sie
sind glücklich das ist ein zerrbild das
stimmt nicht das kann auch nicht im
jetzt würde ich mal gerne einen kurzen
break machen aber beim thema glück und
zufriedenheit bleiben das sind lesen
auch sehr wichtig wie uns auch stichwort
die uiguren die ja auch zu china gehören
ist das glück und zufriedenheit
besonders weit verbreitet in der provinz
shanxi an also ganz im westen wo wir ja
auch informationen haben die eigentlich
ein nicht so schönes eigentlich ein
schlimmes china bild vermitteln ja also
dort in den rhetorischen regionen da
wissen wir inzwischen lassen keine los
anschuldigung das sind das sind taten
die wir schon wissen dass es ein völker
mörderische aktivitäten unterwegs
fakt
herr kurz die waren ja in den schienen
unterwegs gewesen sie haben gesagt das
würde ja alles gar nicht stimmen
weiß ich nicht wo sich überall waren das
ist ja ein wichtiges thema hier neben
hongkong und tibet wird das im moment
besonders diskutiert in bezug auf china
aktueller anlass sind natürlich wieder
die olympischen spiele dass man da ein
augenmerk drauf hat welche erfahrung
haben sie dort gemacht vor ort
also ich möchte einmal läuft dann nach
den lehrer schieben
ausland war schon hier charakterisiert
hat ich bin seit 11 mit einer chinesin
verheiratet
besucht seit 2006 kennen also im
unterschied zu den meisten wollten die
über sieben jahren berichten china von
persönlich von persönlichen begegnungen
und war auch in zehn jahren schon quer
durch die gesamte provinz durch gereist
ich kann nur eins sagen wenn sie heute
in shenyang reisen sehen sie frauen ohne
schleier sehen sie frauen ganz normal
auf den straßen sich bewegen und da
bekomme ich nichts vorgeführt weil ich
das gar nicht weil ich gar keine furth
nicht ich habe mal eine reise gemacht
hier habe ich tatsächlich zusammen auch
mit auto mit mit mit offiziellen gemacht
aber ansonsten reise ich da so durch die
gegend und bekomme überall sehe ich
tanzende frauen auf den straßen dass ich
keine total verkleideten
verdeckten frauen da sehe ich frauen
frauen die ihre rechte haben das ist ein
großer unterschied zu allen zu vielen
anderen muslimische länder ich bin
völlig fasziniert wie sich der westen
gedanken über die muslime in die
schienen young machen und wenn jemand
mehr wissen will empfehle ich in meiner
homepage da kann man den bericht habe
ich das sehr schön auch glaube ich
dargestellt da kann man nachlesen was
ich dort geschrieben habe also auch hier
und wenn sie sagen da würde ein
völkermord stattfinden wenn ein
völkermord stattfindet dann würde es
eine anklage geben seitens des gerichts
internationalen gerichtshofes bis heute
und da wird auch das wird auch von ganz
vielen wissenschaftlern nicht bestätigt
darüber gibt es bis heute keinerlei
vorgänger dass sie china einen
fürchterlichen terrorismus kampf hatte
und dass auch da die offizielle die
staatliche seite nicht nur nett war das
stelle ich überhaupt nicht infrage aber
diese vorwürfe sind sehr sehr politisch
getrieben
tanzende frauen auf den straßen kein
völkermord zu schicken noch kurz weil
wir dann tobias preuß auch nochmal mit
einbeziehen wollen völker mörderische
aktivitäten habe ich gesagt ich will nur
klar stärker metrische aktivitäten
tanzen frauen auf den straßen
ich war seit langem mit den jackson
könnte ich nicht mitreden ich habe es
nicht gesehen das muss ich auch zulässig
auch beweisen weder das eine noch das
andere so richtig beweisen
ich würde aus meiner erfahrung machen
wie wir haben auch auf der stufe tanzte
vor freude
kulturell ist und zu ende war waren
werden die ganze nacht auf der straße
haben wir wirklich super getanzt waren
wir glücklich nein wir waren nicht
glücklich wir waren wirklich angst vor
weil wir ganz genau wissen dient der
neue der jetzt die die macht übernommen
hatte der wollte genauso gefeilt werden
wir haben ihn gefeiert jeder der uns
damals erlebt hatte würde sagen dass uns
ja glücklich tanzende menschen das ist
zwar nicht vergleichbar mit dem was herr
kurze beschrieben hat aber das ist ein
stück lebenserfahrung die nicht nur ich
gemacht habe sondern viele viele andere
chinesen mit den nicht ständigen
austausch über das ich gratuliere ihnen
dass sie mit einer chinesin aussichten
ja verheiratet sind ich bin mir da eine
deutschen frau verheiratet
also ich kenne auch ein bisschen von der
von dem deutschen leben ich will sagen
menschen sind komplexe menschen gerade
in einem solchen system die die werden
hin- und hergerissen egal worum es geht
und gegen das sie also um den runden
tisch spiele geht es erst um die
pandemie
niemand will wirklich eingesperrt werden
die man für welchen gründen auch immer
die deutschen gehen auch auf die straße
und sagen wir wollen uns gar nicht
impfen lassen eine frage ist aber sehr
sehr wichtig dass die leiden der
menschen nicht verschwiegen werden
dürfen ja wenn sie gelitten haben dann
haben sie gelernt dann müssen sie ihren
leiden auch klagen können es ist die
frage wie man dann mit dem mit dem
leiden um geld aber vorher zu sagen sie
haben gar nicht gelitten ich hab das ja
ich habe sie gar nicht leiden sehen
deswegen haben sie auch nicht gelitten
diese haltung kann ich nicht akzeptieren
nur für china nicht sondern für kein
anderes land ich würde ganz kurz weil
tobias preuss ja hier auch noch sitzt
noch mal ganz kurz auf die olympischen
spiele kommen als kleine
zwischenmahlzeit hier in der sendung wir
haben ja über die die den wert dieser
olympische spiele unter diesen
schwierigen bedingungen gesprochen was
welchen wert hat eigentlich wenn ich da
eine gold medaille gewinne welchen wert
hat eigentlich diese goldmedaille in
einem internationalen sportlichen
vergleich unter diesen bedingungen ist
das ein anderer wert muss man da und
fische siege zum beispiel ganz anders
werden als bei spielen die unter anderen
bedingungen stattfinden
ob die ob die wertigkeit der medaille
jetzt bei diesen olympischen spielen
großartig von dem abweicht von den
vorangegangenen
mag ich jetzt für die allgemeinheit
nicht beziffern für die einen wird das
der fall sein für die anderen vielleicht
weniger für die für einige wird es
vielleicht sogar eine bürde sein die sie
gar nicht für sich aufnehmen wollen weil
weil durchaus wie wir jetzt auch in der
bipolarität dieser diskussion merken
dass da durchaus
emotionen auch mitschwingen wo auch
verschiedene meinungen dem dem dieser
dieser veranstaltung gegenüber
vorherrschen und sich es wird ja es wird
ja auch
unter anderem gewisse erwartungen auch
an uns athletinnen gestellt zum beispiel
trete doch einfach nicht an also wie
könnt ihr das moralisch vertreten und so
was solche solche forderungen zimmer
solche solche erwartungen würden
natürlich dann auch unter umständen an
jemanden gehen die oder der oder die
eine eine medaille gewonnen hat und dem
einen sieg errungen hat und da ist es
eben
ja für uns ganz wichtig zu sagen dass
auch ein bisschen nicht ein bisschen was
von einander zu trennen also diese diese
diese verantwortung die athleten darauf
die schultern gelegt wird in form
solcher erwartungen die die sind einfach
mehr als als unfair wir waren nicht an
der vergabe an der entscheidung der
vergabe an china für diese spiele
beteiligt hatten keinerlei
mitspracherecht und das ganze jetzt vor
die füße zu legen und uns zu sagen naja
ihr müsst ja nicht ihr könnt ja das
halte ich einfach für falsch dass
athleten sollen in zukunft auch
beteiligt werden an bei diesem
vergabeentscheidungen das gesund
natürlich ja also athleten athletinnen
sind ja sind letzten endes die
wichtigsten die wichtigste gruppe in
dieser in diesem sport system in dieser
in dieser an diesem system das
organisieren des profisports und den
olympischen spielen sind wie die firma
sind wie die mächtigste absolut gar
nicht also deswegen design definitiv
wir brauchen einen geschmack recht wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine wir haben
brauchen einen platz am tisch mit
absolut definitiv und wir brauchen auch
die die zusage von von von verbänden von
von von von institutionen auch unsere
unsere kraft auch zu nutzen und zum
beispiel auch in momenten wie der der
meinungsfreiheit wo ich sage ich möchte
mich gerne äußern ich möchte gerne diese
rolle die mir auf vertragen wurde
beziehungsweise in dich rein gewachsen
wurde viele viele athleten wollten oder
oder haben explizit nie eine rolle des
vorbildes gesucht sie sind da
reingerutscht weil sie gut in dem waren
was sie als kind in aller regel einfach
wahnsinnig gerne gemacht haben und sind
dann eine rolle rein kommen wo sie
plötzlich vorbilder wurden wenn man wenn
man kinder fragt wollt ihr einmal
vorbild sein oder seht ihr dass das
passiert glaube ich dass keine sagen
würde ja auf jeden fall ich sehe das
definitiv und dementsprechend ist es
aber auch in dieser rolle die die uns
auferlegt wird oder in diese wir ein
rutsch wesentlich oder nicht ist es
einfach auch an uns zu entscheiden wie
möchte ich mich äußern und vor allem auf
wo möchte ich mich äußern und diese die
das ioc sagt zwar ja die
meinungsfreiheit athletinnen ist
unbeschränkt und sie dürfen sagen und
tun was sie was sie möchten und sich
dementsprechend äußern ist
insofern auch wichtig als dass es aber
wiederum beschränkt ist auf gewisse auf
gewisse städten bzw
zonen so dass und davon ausgeschlossen
sind aber die stätten wo es am
wirkungsvollsten ist das podium ist ist
die wettkampfstätte und wir sagen auch
diesbezüglich diese regel 50 die muss
aufgeweicht werden insofern dass das da
auch athletinnen und athleten ihr
statement abgeben können und ihre
meinung frei äußern dürfen insofern sie
natürlich erhalt der leitlinien für für
menschenrechte in deutschland wird nur
sagen der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung
dementsprechend passieren und dass das
ein recht das uns zusteht und das
verlangen wir ebenso auf wie die
mitsprache oder die einbeziehung nicht
nur oder sondern und die einbeziehung in
zb
der prozesse und der stelle schluss
machen die sendung ist nämlich zu ende
zumindest das was jetzt gesagt haben ja
die winterspiele in peking freiwillig
oder unfreiwillig an den tag gebracht
ich bedanke mich hier in studio bei die
dicksten tableau bei chieming war jürgen
kurths zugeschaltet aus shanghai und bei
tobias preuss ebenfalls zugeschaltet
liebe zuschauer die das nächste aktuelle
phoenix gesprächsformat das ist am
montag um 22.15 unter den linden mit
michaela kolster
und jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit anja
chalet da geht es um die olympischen
spiele da werden wir noch mal sehr viel
tiefer einsteigen in diese materie rund
um die olympischen spiele die in china
beginnen bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]